morning to you taliban fighters have
taken jalalabad afghanistan's fifth
largest city and now have control of all
the major cities apart from the capital
kabul
well these pictures have just come in
from jalalabad the taliban said to have
taken the city without a fight
it's because of scenes like this that
the uk is joining other nations trying
to bring its citizens home the united
states has started flying out embassy
staff 5 000 troops are being used for
the operation for ordinary afghans
however the worry is what taliban rule
will mean
because the fall of kabul is seen by
many as inevitable so let's see how the
taliban have advanced and this first map
shows afghanistan in april when the u.s
started their withdrawal in just four
months they've advanced rapidly towards
the capital kabul the government area is
shrinking in the face of the offensive
with militants taking control of logar
province yesterday also yesterday three
more key areas fell to taliban control
the city of mazari sharif the lagman
province and de kundi province
and this morning jalalabad in the east
of afghanistan
taliban fighters are now just miles from
kabul from where our chief correspondent
stuart ramsey reports
it's almost unheard of to see this
number of afghan special forces in one
place at one time
they're regrouping in kabul they're well
trained and heavily armed together
they're a formidable force
but they're desperately needed in the
capital the taliban are just miles away
now
steadily the british and american
soldiers and crucially their equipment
are arriving at kabul
transporter planes land and crisscross
the runways moving towards the military
section of the airport complex
vitally important helicopter gunships
are being prepared for imminent
deployment to protect the evacuation of
foreign nationals and the afghan workers
employed here for two decades
the 600 british soldiers from the 16th
air assault brigade have been loaded
onto planes and will immediately secure
the airport and prepare to assist in the
withdrawal on arrival
it's hoped these british and american
troops will cause the taliban to
hesitate in attacking
afghanistan's president ashraf ghani is
quickly losing his grip here
many thought he would stand down but
he's told the nation he intends to
restore order the holy medona [ __ ]
warren dayton niger honest our dear
country afghanistan is in serious danger
of instability due to the war imposed on
us i'm aware of the situation in
afghanistan
in the current situation the
reintegration of the security and
defense forces is our priority and
serious measures are being taken in this
regard
in the midst of tightening security the
government held hours of talks
discussing a taliban alpha of a
cease-fire and an interim government
it came to nothing
well both the government and the taliban
have rejected previous proposals that
could have brought about a ceasefire in
some form of power sharing the latest
proposal from the taliban involved the
president standing down which he's
rejected the fact that he said he's
going to go after the taliban
can only mean bad news for kabul
and more importantly for the people who
live here
many we spoke to said all they wanted
was peace and some said they'd accept
the taliban especially if they showed
they had changed right now it's fine
the people is good with them they
said
everyone can go to school the girls the
boys life is normal but in the future we
don't know right yes but right recently
life has become difficult for people
people worried about the how
the way taliban treated us before and
now it's a little different the question
is can you trust them to be nice
well we just want peace
but the early indicators of a reformed
taliban aren't looking good in kandahar
they've taken over the radio station
it's now sharia radio
women know they'll suffer the most
only a few are so defined
[Music]
are you scared now i'm not scared if i'm
a girl you know i know that taliban is
fighting in um
that's the entry gate of kabul they are
here i'm not afraid of them we are not
the people who will you know go back to
the dark era i'm a girl and i don't care
about anyone not pakistan not america
nobody else i'm here even today if they
kill me if they identify me i will not
care about them
i will not care about them what should i
be scared of this is my homeland milan
change is coming here now whatever the
president says the taliban's inexorable
advance on kabul is almost complete
the coalition forces will likely only
delay the inevitable
stuart ramsey sky news kabul
let's talk to our foreign affairs editor
deborah haynes and it certainly seems to
be almost inevitable deborah that that
kabul will fall at some point
pretty soon just while the the
international community at the moment
just seems to be looking on
absolutely and i mean the fall of
jalalabad today this morning is kind of
the final the final hurdle before kabul
kabul now the only major major city in
afghanistan under government control and
that follows it's only a week really
it's been just over a week that these
provincial capital after provincial
capital has fallen many barely with a
fight including jalalabad the reports
from there suggesting that the um the
government the government there just
allowed the taliban to take over and
images emerging from the city which is
um in the east of the country um a key
gateway between pakistan
and afghanistan
which is now under taliban control same
two with mazari sharif which is that
northern hub that fell to the taliban
yesterday there had been fighting around
the outskirts but once they got into the
city it does seem
that the those in charge um just succumb
to the inevitable taliban advance which
is what most are expecting is going to
happen with kabul kabul obviously much
much different given the huge
international what had been a huge
international presence is still a
relatively large international presence
and president joe biden who is the man
who has um ordered this withdrawal he
you know he he was handed the cards left
for him by president trump who struck
the deal with the taliban last year and
set that timetable in motion for
american troops to leave the country
president biden finally issued a
statement last night
in which he really doubled down on his
plan to withdraw american troops from
the country but he is sending in
additional forces to withdraw this
diplomatic presence as well and that was
not the initial plan the hope had been
for the u.s and the uk to be able to
retain embassies in the capital clearly
that has changed given the events of the
last few days um but there are going to
be additional american troops 5 000 in
total including 1 000 that were already
in kabul now helping with the evacuation
the embassy staff are starting to be
moved out of the country the uk is also
sending in 600 troops to help evacuate
its diplomats and other um dependents
and people with links to the uk um
reports today that the ambassador is
going to be um leaving the country and
again that is very different the plan
had been for the british embassy to stay
functioning and the fallback plan that
an embassy of some sort would function
from the airport but that's clearly all
been changing because of this taliban
advance that as stuart ramsey was
reporting it does feel inevitable the
big question though is what is going to
happen in kabul joe biden in his
statement last night did set a red line
really saying to the taliban that any
attacks on american forces would be met
with a swift and strong response they've
clearly got additional forces now to be
able to deliver that response so will
the taliban heed that warning will they
wait until this evacuation is over or
will they continue with the push
straight away and risk a direct
confrontation with u.s and potentially
british forces
okay deborah for now thank you
hundreds of people have been killed in
haiti after a major earthquake hit the
west of the country 304 people are
confirmed dead 1800 injured and the
authorities say hundreds more are
missing the earthquake was even more
powerful than the one that devastated
the country in 2010 killing more than
200 000 people
the epicenter of the quake was about 90
miles west of the capital porto prince
our u.s correspondent martha kelner
reports
the people of haiti have dealt with
similar devastation but it doesn't
lessen the horror nor the panic
as water flows through the streets
people ask desperately where it's coming
from the threat of a tsunami looming
we'll do it
[Music]
the earthquake struck at breakfast time
buildings folding in on themselves with
little warning the epicenter was 75
miles from the capital porto prince and
many of these areas are cut off from
rescue teams
people dig through rubble with garden
spades and their bare hands
following the screams of family and
neighbours
on this occasion they're successful
rescuing a woman and young boy despite
the danger of more aftershocks
but hundreds of people are confirmed to
have died and most expect that number
will continue to rise
haiti is a
poor country as you know it does but uh
we
we we never prepared for anything happen
if it is a
earthquake or whatever it is
haiti was still recovering from the 2010
earthquake which took more than 200 000
lives scarred impoverished and angry at
government which has failed to rebuild
but nature has no respect for how much
the people of this country have suffered
along the same fault line a shake even
more powerful than the one which caused
such loss and this is a country already
on its knees reeling from the
assassination of its president last
month overtaken in some areas by violent
gangs
are you concerned about a potential
humanitarian crisis given how precarious
the situation was in haiti even before
this earthquake yeah it's unfolding
right before our eyes very concerned um
it was it's been a very difficult two
two and a half years for
the people of haiti because of political
unrest because of covid
and now this
the full extent of the destruction and
death is still unknown because many of
the communities affected are rural and
hard to reach haiti is also in the path
of tropical storm grace which could
hamper rescue efforts for the people of
this island the onslaught of bad fortune
continues
martha kellner sky news
well the women's number two tennis
player naomi osaka has promised to
donate all the prize money from her next
tournament the relief efforts in haiti
her father is haitian and she said in a
tweet i know our ancestors blood is
strong will keep rising
a man who tried to help one of the
plymouth shooting victims has told sky
news at the moment he came face to face
with a gunman but pinkerton was captured
on a car dash cam trying to comfort kate
shepard moments after she'd been shot
and says he now wishes he'd been able to
tackle jake davidson he's been talking
to ashley huranak
these are kate shepard's final moments
she has just been shot by jake davison
the figure comforting her as a stranger
who happened to be walking by
this was burt pinkerton i've got the
corner of her jacket
so
to stop air getting it and put it across
and then put pressure on and then i was
holding around and speaking to her all
the time they
what are you saying to her help is on
his way hope is on his way you're all
right i'm here with you but like she had
her eyes closed
seriously sort of trying to breathe burt
says he acted instinctively the moment
keeps replaying in his head but the
haunting figure of davidson also scars
his memory
just blank expression me that was just
staring through you basically you know
he was like dressed in black
like a black t-shirt a big black beard
like black charlie chair
walking like he was on control like a
soldier with a gun pointing down the cat
and walking for six minutes on thursday
night davidson roamed his neighborhood
shooting dead five people including his
mother and a little girl
kate shepherd was jake davison's last
victim before he turned the gun on
himself just beyond that cordon the
community here have been left reeling
from the events of the last few days
they are desperate to understand how
this happened and to heal
the tributes continue to build including
from the home secretary who on a visit
yesterday spoke to locals and police
a minute silence at plymouth argyle's
first home match of the season also
allowed for quiet reflection
the events of that day weigh heavily on
this city particularly for this
samaritan who has a memory of that
evening he wants to erase but there are
reminders of the horrors right on his
doorstep
horizon sky news in plymouth
four people were in hospital with
suspected gun wounds after reports of a
drive-by shooting in camden north london
it took place near regent's park just
after 10 last night the condition of
four people hurt isn't yet known the
area is cordoned off police have been
given increased stop and search powers
across camden overnight
20 people have died after a fuel tanker
exploded in northern lebanon according
to the red cross there the charity said
its teams recovered bodies from the site
of the explosion and evacuated 79 people
who were injured or suffered burns in
the blast
the ivory coast has recorded its first
case of ebola in 25 years
it was detected in an 18 year old
traveling from guinea which suffered a
small outbreak earlier in the year the
health minister said it was an isolated
case and the patient is being treated in
intensive care
at least 44 people are confirmed dead
after flash flooding in turkey severe
flooding and mudslides hit the black sea
region on wednesday destroying buildings
sweeping away cars and cutting off power
but there are fears the number of dead
could rise
as the search for missing people
continues
spain set a new provisional heat record
as searing temperatures gripped the med
a high of 47.2 celsius recorded in the
city of montoro in the south of the
country yesterday
in portugal several districts are on a
state of alert because of the increased
risk of wildfires
and let's have a look at the
live impact of climate change the top
line here showing how the uk's power is
produced 31 renewables 28 nuclear that's
the bulk of it so far but still 41
fossil fuels most of which is gas
um
the global warming since 1880 that's
when records began with 1.23 degrees so
that leaves according to scientists
about 11 and a half years until we hit
1.5 degrees celsius which is the point
of no return according to them and a lot
of that of course down to co2 emissions
you can see the total carbon dioxide
emissions
is almost two and a half million
million
tons
and all the very latest on the cloud of
course on our daily climate show here on
sky news every week day at half six and
half nine
now all 16 and 17 year olds in england
are to be offered a first cover jab
within the next eight days ready for the
start of the academic year
in september becky cottrell's following
this one for us this morning so making
that available to all in that age group
do we know how many people are still
unvaccinated from that age group
it's not uh
not as many as the government would like
basically they were offered the job
earlier in the month but the government
has brought in that deadline of august
23rd in the hope that it will encourage
all 16 and 17 year olds to go and get a
jab before they go back to school the
government wants august 23rd to be the
deadline because that provides two weeks
before the new term starts in september
there had been concern that with
children going back to school students
going back to university that could
trigger an escalation in cases obviously
people over 18 have already been given
their job or offered their job but that
is why the government has brought in
this younger age group specifically to
target the older school students 16 to
17 year olds they can book an
appointment through their gp or go to a
walk-in center currently the advice is
for money to get one dose of the jab not
two that is being reviewed though
children between 12 and 15 uh who are
clinically vulnerable or who live with
someone who's clinically vulnerable they
are also being offered the job but no
word yet on whether uh children more
generally in those younger age age
groups will get the vaccine it hasn't
been ruled out yet but it is not the
current protocol
obviously all of this that i'm talking
about applies to england but there is a
similar situation in wales northern
ireland and scotland 16 to 17 year olds
being offered that jab and encouraged to
get it before the new school term starts
okay becky thank you let's have a look
at the latest covert data for you and
there have been a further 29
520 cases in the last day
a further 93 people have died which
takes the total number of deaths now to
a hundred and thirty thousand eight
hundred and ninety four
in terms of the vaccines uh nearly uh 40
000 first doses were given in the last
day 166 000 second doses
40.3 million people are now fully
vaccinated
this is sky news breakfast let's see
what the weather's gonna do for you good
morning joe a bit of a mixed bag again
it is i'm afraid it's really not looking
very good is it not the summer that uh
we'd like to think we were going to have
but there is some hope inside it may
turn a little bit warmer at the end of
this coming week but for the time being
we pick up this northwesterly flow which
is a little bit cool let's take a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well
with today we've got this area of low
pressure it's just sitting
over southwestern parts of ireland and
it's throwing a lot of cloud and some
patchy rain for these southern areas
also for parts of wales and the
southwest then we want a secondary rain
belt across northern parts of england
that's trying to work its way southwards
and then to the north of that it's
fresher cooler a mixture of sunny spells
and scattered showers for much of
scotland and northern ireland through
the course of the day so really we're
looking at a fair amount of cloud across
england and wales that's going to be
giving some patchy rain and drizzle here
and there perhaps some heavier rain over
these northern areas
best of the weather for parts of east
anglia and the far south east where we
could see temperatures up to around 24
25 degrees celsius 77 degrees fahrenheit
is still a notch down on yesterday and
then cooler and fresher in the north
those air temperatures really mid to
late teens and through the course of the
day that uh patchy rain starts to clear
away it eventually gets away overnight
we see some clear spells developing but
western areas will be cloudy tomorrow
jackie thank you still to come for you
this morning the government's latest
move to crack down on shark finning
[Music]
can you hear me now
now shark finning that's the act of
cutting off a shark's fin before
throwing it back into the water has
received widespread condemnation for
decades now and it's prohibited in many
waters around the world the practice has
been banned in the uk but the
government's going a step further and
introducing new legislation to stop
imports and exports of the finns from
other countries well let's talk to ali
hood director of conservation at the
shark trust morning to you i mean what
sort of difference will this make well
we very much welcome this recent
statement from death row which
reinforces their commitment to shark
conservation through this proposed
prohibition in trade and detached shark
fins
i mean the fin trade
has been a driver of decades of
uncontrolled shark fishing leading to
the decline of many species oceanic
sharks for example those on the high
seas like the blue shark in this footage
have declined by nearly three quarters
over the last 50 years mainly due to
uncontrolled fishing driven historically
by the fin trade however statistics now
indicate a declining trend in this trade
due to title regulations and consumer
campaigns
meanwhile though the trade in shark meat
and other products is increasing and
hence the need to see the fin trade as
an element of the wider issue of
overfishing so this move by the uk
is is a really important statement um
out to the wider global community
i mean just what sort of trade is there
in shark fins
in the uk i mean it is is there a lot of
it coming to the uk so the the uk fin
trade is is not um
is is not
immense in any way um however it this is
a an issue of strong principle the uk
has been a leader in a number of shark
conservation issues and to enable it to
take a strong stance
on the global stage it's essential that
we as a country are
coming from a very strong position so
the uk has not only pledged to bring an
end to the import and export to detach
shark fins but also to increase its
engagement in high seas fisheries
management in
wildlife
instruments like societies and cms and
this is very much evident in the uk's
current role as a champion um in the
north atlantic of the short fin maker a
species that has clear scientific advice
for a prohibition on retention in what's
known as icat fisheries
but a position that's been stalled and
blocked by the eu and
the us so the uk along with other
champion countries like canada is
pushing for
the strictest protection here this is
something it can do from its position as
a strong sharp champion across the board
i i mean as we look at those pictures of
of
you know traders sort of gathering and
measuring shark fins i've got to ask the
question
why on earth i mean what
what is the appeal of shark fin to
people
i mean this is something that has a
cultural basis so you could ask that
question about many products um that are
consumed in different countries around
the world i think the key thing here is
that there has been and there still is a
financial value attached to shark fin
that is extremely high and where there
is a financial interest then you're
going to get to trade
right right but this i mean this is i
mean my understanding is there are
the imports of things like shark fin
soup and things into the uk that will
that will all stop as a result of this
will it so anything that includes a
detached shark fin um will will cease
once this legislation is in in place um
that ensures that any shark that enters
the uk trade system with its fins still
attached has come from a fishery that
practices what's known as fins naturally
attached it's a far simpler
sort of fisheries management to enforce
it increases the knowledge on that
fishery we can identify the sharks that
are landed and it is the correct step
towards more sustainable fishing
practices
ali good to talk to you thank you
this is sky news breakfast let's have a
look at the weather for you with joe
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well the
weather's a little mixed to start the
day we've got an area of low pressure
close to ireland that's uh throwing a
lot of cloud and some patchy rain around
we've got a rain belt over northern
parts of england and then we've got uh
showers over scotland so it's a kind of
a three-way split today but we should
see some brightness particularly down
towards the south
uh cloud extending across into parts of
wales in the southwest will eventually
bring some patchy rain to central
southern parts as well temperatures a
little bit disappointing we managed 26
yesterday today are likely to be 24 or
25 but for many parts particularly these
northern areas it's likely to be cooler
temperatures in the late teens and then
through this evening and overnight the
area of low pressure drifts away to the
near continent so it takes a lot of the
cloud with it and the patchy rain so
we're turning uh quite clear in places
overnight still a few showers around and
quite a bright start to monday morning
but we're also going to see this
northwesterly breeze setting in this
could be quite strong around the coast
so feeling cool there but it's a cool
direction and temperatures will be that
bit lower as well and through the course
of the morning western areas will tend
to cloud up a little
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
joe thank you stay with us we'll take
you through the papers in a couple of
minutes
[Music]
did you know that drive
did you
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air at drop-off and
pick-up times
low pressure will move across the
country over the next 24 hours and it'll
leave us with quite a cool northwesterly
breeze
as far as today is concerned we're
looking at large amounts of clouds some
outbreaks of rain and drizzle here and
there and bits and pieces of brightness
where we do get some warmth temperatures
around 24 25 degrees celsius are not
down on yesterday whereas in the north
we're looking in the late teens celsius
in terms of the air quality well
pollution levels will be low or very low
over the next couple of days on account
of the air coming from the atlantic
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
time for the papers this morning with
the broadcaster and author gemma forte
and entrepreneur kate hardcastle morning
youtube once again gemma let's kick
straight off with the sunday time should
we what are they saying about the w.h.o
and china when it comes to the pandemic
well this is a very long read so if
you're up and about this morning and you
want to grab a cup of tea and read some
amazing investigates investigative
journalism i would thoroughly recommend
this piece the headline is china the who
and the power grab that fueled a
pandemic
and it's quite a disturbing read really
brought to you by the same journalists
who wrote the incredible scoop months
ago about boris johnson missing all
those cobra meetings
and it really is
very very detailed so essentially when
the sars outbreak happened in 2003 china
decided it didn't like the criticism
that followed it didn't accept the
public humiliation and they weren't
going to allow it to happen again
so it appears that since then they have
severely compromised the independence
and leadership of the w80
and in terms of installing chosen
candidates and definitely prioritizing
economic interest over halting the
spread of this virus
so it's fairly sinister to be honest
with you
and um
they also sort of kept perpetuating
false claims that the virus couldn't be
spread for humans and so on so of course
this has meant that orders weren't
closed as quickly as they should have
been essentially the worlds didn't have
a heads up
when four million people have died um
since
um
this needs to be looked into and of
course going forward you know china
represents other kinds of threats cyber
security and so on so how does the world
react how do we deal with this um
certainly one would
think that perhaps seeking future trade
deals isn't the way forward but how do
you hold a regime like china to account
but it really is a fascinating read yeah
it sounds it and as you say it poses a
lot of
very big questions to which i'm
quite sure people do not at this moment
have answers
to the independents uh kate looking at i
mean haiti
what a time it's had over the last 11
years i mean now another earthquake
and they've not recovered from the
devastating 2010 earthquake either and
this is a place that is as we know
struggling politically financially and
they've seen homes destroyed again
people have died the hospital's
overwhelmed
this is just an incredibly sad piece of
news as we understand that that 7.2
magnitude earthquake has made such
impact of only 100 miles from the
capital and the prime minister there
saying that it's been a creation of
enormous damage i think
we can only just read this and try and
understand just how a country trying to
rebuild itself is once again set back as
well as dealing with the same issues
it has for many years uh economy
particularly yeah yeah
i mean such a poor country and to be
dealing with this against huge amount of
international help
and to the sunday express gemma looking
at
a pandemic but this one of anxiety
yes that's right it's almost a sort of
concurrent uh pandemic that has been
spreading if you like um this piece
takes
um well they keep citing this ex uh john
mcpherson and i'm not completely
comfortable with some of the language
that he uses although he makes
extraordinarily valid points so he talks
about campaign of fear he talks about
brainwashing
um obviously we had we
the government had to make some fairly
hard hitting messages hit home in order
to curb the virus and i've got a 16 year
old and a 14 year old and absolutely
without a doubt i know that them and
their friends have suffered immensely it
is not natural to be cooped up in a
house with your parents for a year or
whatever it just isn't and the way that
they've studied etc however some have
coped well some haven't everybody's
circumstances are different and i think
what is more helpful now
is how can we now help them going
forward to adapt again i think the
positive news is that our brains are
plastic we have this plasticity we are
incredibly adaptive look how we as
humans did adapt once we got our heads
around the fact that this undefeated
happened we got on with it and now the
world is opening up again and we're
adapting again so i don't think it's all
doom and gloom um we just have to find
ways to support them as much as possible
and make sure yes that they're not
terrified about going out now that the
vaccine is is is working broadly you
know i know there are still
things to worry about to an extent but i
know that i'm trying to help my daughter
uh sort of get back to normal life
i mean look i might be totally wrong
here but when it comes to young people
and anxiety a lot of a lot of young
people but you'll suffer very genuinely
from anxiety but is there also that
issue of people you know it's
if you tell a youngster they're going to
be
stressed they get stressed and we are we
sort of feeding them a little bit
but perhaps you know they have had these
messages as it says in the piece about
you know don't go near granny you'll
kill her you know these are
extraordinary things to be told as a
young person and they've they've taken
it on and i think i know earlier we were
talking about exam results that you said
stephen you know your nephew i think
have done extraordinarily well and again
hand in hand with that
i i was a bit against the the kind of
mode where the press were talking about
results going through the roof and sort
of almost intimating that exams are
easier they're not i think this
generation work harder than my peers did
and do seem to take things more
seriously and have more perhaps social
justice and awareness of what's going on
around the world perhaps that's because
they're so plugged into their bones i
don't know so yeah anxiety a really huge
issue as is eating disorders that's been
another pandemic so we just have to now
be really proactive and and and positive
actually and rather than talking about
scaremongering and and all that stuff
that sort of has happened i think we
need to be looking forward yeah and to
help right okay kate what's going on in
uh with m s in the mail on sunday
well the mail on sunday aren't very
happy that the rumors about eminem's
christmas advert are going to be
the the feature apparently markup
spencer's advert features a work
activist i'm just going to edge off that
for a while because whatever you do for
your christmas campaign m s do what you
want but i think this is an organization
that we love to talk about the consumers
love to write to me when i talk about
the results at mns they care for them
they're a brand that's got a huge amount
of affection still just like john lewis
as well but they're a ban a brand that's
been in trouble for many many years
wherever you go with the advertising
here i think this is an organization
that has consumers begging and pleading
for it to return to its original values
of value and quality and i think when it
has struggled so many years now for its
fashion lines for its financial figures
we've just seen a massive store closure
program
however much is invested in any tune of
christmas campaign
as i always say the detail the basics
has to be there so what i'd like to be
reading about m s who've just taken on
an additional set of brands that they're
going to sell all brands that are
existing all brands that are resold
somewhere else don't really get that as
a complete strategy is an organization
that actually gives back to its
consumers and does the right thing so i
am i'm concerned to say the least what
the spectacle of christmas adverts are
going to be this year and they were very
poignant and thoughtful last year when
we saw them it is a time for us to have
a bit of joy and fun i suppose but um
whatever the spokesperson for the brand
the brands underneath it have to deliver
the right message for the consumer day
in day out that's the plate yeah yeah no
totally get that
let's have a look at banksy and the
observer gemma
are you a fan are you a banksy fan
you are you nodding i am are you i just
i just wish you'd put the spray cans
away and sort of let walls be walls
do you you see i i completely don't i
would i he's welcome to come and do a
piece of art on the front of my house
i really enjoy his art and actually um
also the people that that have it
imposed upon them admittedly
um
it's incredibly valuable i'm sure it
would add value to those buildings but i
do understand i think the thing is that
spray can art has always been associated
with graffiti business vandalism if you
just don't
um but but with banksy i feel it is
different the art is really well thought
about it's always poignant it makes a
point and it
it's um
it always works with the environment and
in this case he's been going around uh
norfolk and suffolk and he's been having
a spray occasion um
and i love the mystique behind banksy as
well nobody knows it is it's it's very
clever it is certainly clever we're out
of time we'll see you soon in an hour